- [Instructor] We're told
the polynomial p of x,
which is equal to this, has
a known factor of x plus six.
Rewrite p of x as a
product of linear factors.
Pause this video, and see if
you can have a go at that.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
Because they give us one of the factors,
what we can do is say hey,
what happens if I divide
x plus six into p of x?
What do I have left over?
It looks like I'm still
going to have a quadratic,
and then I'll probably
have to factor that somehow
to get a product of linear factors.
So let's get going.
So if I were to try to figure out
what x plus six divided into,
x to the third plus nine x squared,
and now we're gonna have to be careful.
You might be tempted to
just write minus 108 there,
but then this gets tricky
because you have your third degree column,
your second degree column.
You need your first degree column,
but you just put your zero degree,
your constant column here.
So to make sure we have good hygiene,
we could write plus zero x,
and I encourage you to
actually always do this
if you're writing out a polynomial
so that you don't skip
that place, so to speak,
minus 108.
And so then you say, all right,
let's look at the highest degree terms.
X goes into x to the
third x squared times.
X squared times six is six x squared.
X squared times x is x to the third.
We want to subtract.
We've done this multiple times,
so I'm going a little
bit faster than normal.
Those cancel out.
Nine x squared minus six x
squared is three x squared.
Bring down that zero x.
And then how many times does
x go into three x squared?
Well, it goes three x times,
and we would write it in this column.
And notice, if we didn't keep this column
for our first degree terms,
we'd be kind of confused
where to write that
three x right about now.
And so three x plus, times
six, I should say, is 18 x.
Three x times x is three x squared.
We want to subtract what we have in that,
I guess that color is mauve,
light purple, not sure.
And so we get three x squareds cancel out,
and then zero x minus 18 x
is negative 18 x.
Bring down that negative 108.
And so then we have
x goes into negative 18 x
negative 18 times.
Negative 18 times six is
negative 108.
That's working out nicely.
Negative 18 times x is negative 18 x.
And then we want to subtract
what we have in this
not-so-pleasant brown color,
and so I will multiply
them both by a negative.
And so I am left with zero.
Everything just cancels out.
And so I can rewrite p of x.
I can rewrite p of x
as being equal to x plus six
times x squared plus three x minus 18.
But I'm not done yet because
this is not a linear factor.
This is still quadratic.
So let's see, can I think of two numbers
that add up to three
and that when I multiply
I get negative 18?
So I'll need different signs,
and then the obvious one
is positive six and negative three.
And if that, what I just did,
seems like voodoo to you,
I encourage you to review
factoring polynomials.
But this I can rewrite
'cause negative six plus,
or actually I should say positive six
plus negative three is equal to three,
and then positive six times negative three
is equal to negative 18.
So I can rewrite this as x plus six times
x plus six times
x minus three.
And so there we have it.
We have a product of linear factors.
And we are done.